speaking of the 49ers the problem they
now have is they're trying to muster a
trade market for jimmy garoppolo the guy
they decided they didn't want anymore
thus they gave up three first round
picks and a third round pick to get
ultimately
trey lance the quarterback from north
dakota state jed york owner of the 49ers
aka guy who can't be fired because as he
said once you can't fire the owner
talking about nbc sports or talking with
nbc sports bay area about the 49ers
quarterback situation here's jed york
we are in a situation where
jimmy goes out and takes us to the super
bowl again and and has an mvp caliber
season there there are worse dilemmas to
be in and jimmy certainly has the
ability to do that i think kyle's talked
about that all along and knowing it's
the most important position in sports
and it's great to have a guy that you
you do believe in that that has gotten
you to a super bowl so you don't have to
put the weight of the world on a rookie
whoever it was we were going to choose
now that we know that trey is here
you don't have to put the weight of the
world on that kid's shoulders and he can
grow into that position you invest
25 or 50 million dollars into your
rookie to get them ready
then i mean to me like we're we're
investing in the long-term future of our
team
you know this sunday he turns 21
if he doesn't play until he's 23
you know but he's got a 15 plus year
career i mean you know there were rumors
about a guy and obviously kyle talked
about trading for aaron how long did
aaron sit two three years before he
played and and again
i want to make sure that we do
everything that we can to make sure that
that position is the best can possibly
be in the nfl we're trying to build out
a team that can compete for a
championship today and can compete for a
championship over a period of time and
we'll make the best decisions
not where well you know you trade it up
in like this is a third pick and he has
to play right now well i mean if if he's
the best player then then he would play
and if he's not ready to do it yet we're
not going to put that on his shoulders
boy jed york completed the trifecta
there by making a reference to aaron
rodgers player under contract with the
green bay packers i think they need to
have a seminar at the 49ers headquarters
to make sure they understand where that
bright line is and to stay away from it
but the bigger issue this idea that they
would let garoppolo finish out a
contract he's got two years left and
when jed york speaks of investing 25 or
50 million in getting trade lance ready
that means spending 50 million over the
next two years to keep jimmy garoppolo
around
i just have a hard time
understanding how you justify giving up
three first round picks and a third
round pick for the guy that you just put
on ice
while you see whether or not the guy
that you have can somehow stay healthy
because it's not like it's an
impossibility it's basically a coin flip
they flipped it in 2018 can't stay
healthy flipped it in 2019 stayed
healthy flipped it in 2020 can't stay
healthy odds are this year he stays
healthy and what if you do get to the
super bowl despite jimmy garoppolo not
because of him but despite him despite
the fact that he'll freak out kyle
shanahan at some point shannon will turn
him into bob griese in the postseason
have him throw eight times in the nfc
championship despite the fact it'll miss
emmanuel sanders when he's open with the
championship on the line
i i just i think you got to be more
decisive and and look maybe it's all
puffery maybe it's all bs maybe they're
just trying to pump this guy up so they
can get at least a second round pick
back for him i just choose not to buy it
because i think if it's not an effort to
get more out of jimmy garoppolo they are
asking for a major problem here by not
being as decisive as they need to be
sharing
well i i see their thinking on this mic
because they do think they have a super
bowl caliber team i get that only a
couple years ago they were in the super
bowl and jimmy g was starting the super
bowl trey lance is not going to lead
this team to super bowl he's a kid that
started 17 games and he started at the
fcs level so this is not a power five
quarterback with a ton of experience
like saying mac jones or somebody else
who kelemond who maybe is more ready
having played in the power five uh
conference for a long time with with a
lot of start so i i get
why they're doing this but yeah at some
point you have to make that decision
right and i've said all along i think
the packers timeline changed when aaron
rodgers did what he did last year in
winning the mvp award but they have put
the weight of the world on jimmy
garoppolo it's an mbp caliber season or
a super bowl is basically what jed york
said to keep your job so at some point
all these teams have good intentions
when they go and say hey our rookie is
going to sit and we're just going to
wait and see we saw tua come in and play
last year we saw justin herbert now his
was a little different because of an
injury came in and played last year they
all want them to sit but at some point
you got to see what you have so with the
first misstep by jimmy garoppolo trey
lance is going to get his opportunity so
jimmy garoppolo's got to go in he's got
to play well and the 49ers have to win
for him to keep his job and at some
point you trade him the question is
going to be mike say in training camp he
looks great some starter goes down a la
teddy bridgewater in minnesota
and you have all of a sudden a first
round pick at your disposal do you move
on from him at that point i say yes you
get rid of him whenever because i think
sharing i think that's what they're
trying to set up i think that this is
all bs in an effort to build a market
for jimmy garoppolo you don't give up
three ones in a three
and and then just tuck the guy away for
multiple years and say well we're fine
with jimmy garoppolo it doesn't make
sense unless they've been completely
screwed up by the fact that they could
have had patrick mahomes and they could
have had tom brady and they said no to
both that could be the thing that is
causing them to do something that just
seems goofy and kooky and nutty and
desperate
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports